und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video heute mit einer neuen folge gegen
den 1
und ich möchte heute mal versuchen ich
weiß nicht ob es klappt doch ich möchte
versuchen meine rache für das letzte
fäuste bekommen da habe ich auf meinem
kanal ordentlich abgerissen
ich sage nicht ich heute probleme das
gleich wieder also wenn im kids duelle
lassen erste runde startet jetzt so
erste paket steht auf dem blatt papier
er war opels und heimwerkerkette alter
gibt es kann kein links hier keine speed
pushen die pisco kannst die theoretisch
hier einfach jetzt tränke brauen
aber lass mal lieber die finger davon
sind ist der weg vom zauber mit meine
sache hier bestimmt ob schwert und
kursen verzauberung drauf weiß ich warum
alternativen gibt mit dem minister für
sie okay hier ist aber lieber nicht ins
wasser
denn das ist eine schlechte idee
und natürlich voll der boss fremder
kommt dass sie mal ans festland kommen
damit wir nicht so ein baum orgel gibt
ja kaum trainiert doch gleich mal den
ball dafür wieder ab dem niederrhein
gefasst
jetzt sagt close combat alter
praktikabel jump oder sogar ein lied
gemacht hat 1 runde zwei wir haben jetzt
etwas bisschen weniger hornbach ist
bisschen mehr
heimwerker kitze kommen braun sie sich
ihre tränke in der runde bis zur rolle
ist google ist so schön dass halter guck
mal acht mal genau auf den dow noch bei
ketten und den autoclick und ich hasse
es im wasser zu sein dass ich nicht
alter sieht man sogar enke hat vor dem
us-kongress erste seite bevor sie
wirklich dass auch ein kleiner natürlich
kleiner als bogen
ich hab mein ja alles gut
ja ja jetzt jetzt ja das nicht
auslöschen dankeschön ein wasser das
wasser kampf geht
ich hab keine ahnung
das lag daran wir hatten nun stein
schwert und rüstung wie viel der hitze
einfach etwas kaputtgegangen handeln
aber nahe 2 0 ist nicht schlecht aus
nächste runde darunter wie random house
oder shampoos zwischen array wir wären
lieber sterben oder junge ist es dass
doch wieder dieses komische gibt hat das
wir schon mal hatten oder wieso steigt
und mit dem wird verstärkt die eisen das
schon mal weniger op 64 der finne mit
shampoos alaba kommt gebaut wenn ich
hier eigentlich geben
ich weiß nicht ob ich stand ja wie sie
es bei dir aus lebens mäßig grünbereiche
aber mehr auch nicht wirklich
die lava bahn kommt es jedoch nicht aus
sagt ein bisschen schwimmen
jetzt erwischt naja
hohoho man kann sich dem thema garten
kann das dann irgendwie keine handlung
immer kaffee fertig sterben kein hallo
das ist einfach jetzt einfach voll auf
die fresse mit der achse
bei mir geht es voll
du bist auch wieder hat am gitter
klicken gibst du ein bisschen kannst
wirklich bitter
ich kann es doch überhaupt ja dann kann
ich hab dann kann eben paetzel ganz gut
seinem twitter
aber ob er gut ist oder nicht sehen sie
nicht konnte 33 nicht viel schon oder
eher ja
4.13 uhr für mich läuft alter ohne 4
film ab runde vier steht 3 0 für mich
tatsächlich und die altbewährte die
achse ist wieder on point am fenster das
die ganzen turnier gestellt werden nee
ich nicht was ich sonst aus oder wie
doch dieses war
ich habe heute wird die ultimate hacks
heute drin man bei der hacker schon
gelernt ich kann nie und ein halbes
hertz fallen sobald ich auf einer halben
herzen habe ich den reben 81 und die
resigniert aber nicht unerheblich auf
dem halm merz verständnis besser weg als
leiter des könnte einfach in 50 werden
wenn ich die nächste runde auch mal
mitreißen kann durch haben in runde fünf
so das könnt ihr letzte runde sein
hier sehen wir das kit stupid ok hatten
wir am anfang schon zwei extra herzen ja
meist dann habe ich einfach gerade im
gold ist ein paar nicht beendet das ist
so ein bisschen warm kita bis gefühl
gerne a23 heißhunger 4 beta roboter
textentwurf enthalten
wir wollen nicht gegessen hätte ja das
gibt's nicht
er hat den ball doch durch gegessen what
the [ __ ] mann 950 vergeigt ja jünger
aber es gibt kein talent keine blamage
aber so was die band gibt es nicht
normal heute nächste rote ist die in der
ich gewinnen werde hoffentlich sechs die
finale runde
wenig hat ihm gemeint dass er spürt dass
er in dieser runde verlieren wird gesagt
man kann mich aber nicht erinnern
hast aber gesagt habe ich das aber nicht
doch doch doch das doch die habe ihm
porsche- nerven vereins doch auch ja ja
ja okay kommt jetzt geht mark dittli cdp
5 zu 1 wenigen immer so knappen matches
aber ja sie sei ein halbes herz einmal
ein herz da gibt es zwar keine blamage
und muss man zugute halten das war keine
blamage aber ich bin froh ich habe meine
rache tatsächlich bekommen nachdem ich
zuletzt ich glaube ich hab auch 5 2 1
verloren 5 2 so können videos hier oben
verlinkt wenigen der beschreibung ja
dann danke fürs dabeisein bis zum
nächsten video und schau